kla bonjour c'est fabick scène alors
aujourd'hui on va se faire un nouveau
casse tête s'est pas réellement un casse
tête même si ses nerfs c'est une des
boîtes secrète japonaise fait de manière
artisanale qui est juste super moments
magnifiques juste l'histoire de la boîte
à l'ewf l'histoire de l'histoire de
faire ce genre de boîte c'est ouf
et je sais pas trop ce que ça va donner
la seule chose que je sais moi et donc
je peux vous dire c'est qu'elle se
résout en 12 mouvement qu'on achète ce
genre de boîte on sait le nombre de
mouvements à faire pour pouvoir l'ouvrir
donc 12 mouvement c'est pas si mal je
pense qu'il ya matière à faire une vidéo
et peut-être même de on verra bien je
pense quand même que si on trouve les
genres 4 5 premiers après en
tâtonnements on peut aller jusqu'au bout
juste avant de commencer la vidéo je
vous rappelle que je fais aussi des
petites vidéos de gros plans et de
ralentis de casse tête sur mon instagram
avec lui j'étais vais vous êtes de plus
en plus nombreux et nombreuses à le
suivre
et ça fait plaisir n'hésitez pas à les
voir et puis à me dire là bas que vous
venez d'ici comme ça on retrouve et tant
que j'y suis je vous rappelle également
que la date de l'olympia elle approche
c'est juste après les vacances que je
dévoile l'intégralité du nouveau
spectacle à l'olympia et et on est à 80
% de remplissage donc si vous voulez
venir
il est temps de prendre votre place
c'est parti
alors ce coffret yaws et guy il se fait
en 12 étapes fiona qui seront en quatre
étapes en mythe établissent à saint 12
étapes donc c'est relativement dure le
temps je connais un petit peu ces
coffrets il les produits réellement
artisanalement sur le lac à chier au
japon s'est fait dans un village
d'artisans qui vont des travaux de
marquer free depuis plus de 300 ans
trois cents ans qui font ça aussi des
boissons et ses travaux de marqueterie
qui datent de 710 700 voire début 18
cents ont la particularité de suivre
toujours la forme naturelle du bois la
couleur naturelle du bois les les
nervures naturelles du bois et avec un
procédé de rabotage très spécial ils
fabriquent ce genre de boîte qui sont à
la fois une vraie boîte dont on peut se
servir mais aussi une boîte secrète à
ouverture secrète et là le seul indice
qu'on essaie qu'il ya douze mouvement a
trouvé afin d'ouvrir la boîte donc dans
un premier temps pour moi ce que je veux
qu'on proposait déjà j'appuie là ok la
gamme moov nous dans un premier temps ce
que je veux comprendre ces caisses qui
doit s'ouvrir alors c'est en général la
grande partie supérieure qui souffrent
et qui coulisse je pense que ce sera le
cas mais pour l'instant j'ai pas trop d'
indices là quand j'appuie y ait ici en
fait assez naturellement c'est venu ici
donc j'ai essayé de voir déjà acté ce
qui bouge un peu partout après ça peut
bouger aussi en diagonale de ce
mouvement c'est à la fois chaud est à la
fois assez simple
c'est qu'en général il ya un ordre de
séquencer aussi c'est la 3e ou 4e vidéo
là de deux casse-tête sur la chaîne si
vous avez des idées de casse tête que
vous voulez que je résolvent vous avez
été nombreux par exemple on peut parler
d'excalibur crise rams elle l'a fait sur
sa chaîne je regardais ça a l'air bien
badass c'est bien bien ouf je vais voir
comment me le procurer comment comment
le commander ou le commander je pense
que j'essaierai de le faire sur la
chaîne mais pas une seule vidéo ça c'est
sûr bon j'avais vraiment que ici que ça
bouge ok là ça a bougé aussi
donc en fait ça nous fait un mouvement
ici au mouvement là je trouve ça ouf
tout le système en fait mécanique qui
permet la résolution alors que tout est
fait à la main en bois ça je trouve ça
vraiment génial et puis là nous on a on
a un vrai indices terre que quand tu te
procure lawati c'est le nombre de
mouvements bien il y en a 2 2 c'est pas
mal ou alors si ça se trouve c'est ça
qui s'enlève et j'ai pas compris je sais
pas si vous avez bien vu mais en fait je
viens de pouvoir le pousser plus loin la
danse était comme ça va donc ça ferait
un deux trois peut-être 4 4
5 ok donc j'ai quatre mouvements pour
l'instant premier mouvement je descends
non premier mouvement je pousse ensuite
ce dessin ensuite je peux pousser plus
loin et ensuite je désire c'est
tellement malin c'est un peu des fois
c'est un peu un hasard hein tu tu as un
truc qui bouge
alors là je cherche s'il n'y a pas un
retour ou quoi 1 2 3 a priori pour
l'instant je peux plus rien toucher de
cette phase donc je peux aller chercher
sur une autre phase par ce qui est
possible afflux ok on a un cinquième
mouvement ici alors après ça bute
pourquoi sa [ __ ] donc sa [ __ ] parce que
là il ya un tasseaux de bois qui
cherchent à taper donc l'idée c'est
d'essayer de le visualiser en 3d
donc si ça tape là ça veut dire que il
faut que le dessin de plus c'est un
moment donné en fait en fait je me méfie
parce que dès qu'il fait un autre
mouvement ailleurs tu dis ok ça peut
libérer quelque chose sur quelque chose
que moi j'ai déjà touché
[Musique]
là le truc c'est que il a plus rien qui
bouge en fait c'est très gênant depuis
que j'ai fait cinquième mouvement là
j'en trouve pas un sixième nul part
qu'est-ce que ça une diagonale pea
il y en a un là j'ai un tapis en fait
c'est ça le secret je crois que c'est
vraiment d'appuyer un peu sur les bords
plutôt que de faire ce que je faisais là
d'essayer de d'agripper avec mon pouce
c'est tellement fin que j'ai même pas vu
que le msss a comme travail la nervure
du bois on voit même pas qu'ils aient
une séparation qui est fait ici
[ __ ] c'est complètement invisible
c'est hallucinant
en fait si je le pousse pas j'arrive pas
à voir où est ce qu'ils savent être donc
là ça nous fait un sixième mouvement 6
bonjour reprend la même mécanique que
tegra 2 pouces 7 pts 8
peut-être neuf des dix ça va être beau
donc là je suis à dix mouvements
c'est là que je suis à un mouvement
d'ouvrir la boîte on voit bien dans la
boîte le tasso en fait qui qui m'empêche
de l'autre côté que ça marche
le pij propose d'ailleurs ça donne voilà
et là il ya une grande épaisseur fait
que tu as eu une tape dessus en fait qui
sécurise le truc donc ça fait dix
mouvements dont je vais essayer de tous
les refaire d'un coup
pour voir si ça me paraît assez logique
donc ça ferait 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9
maintenant ça fait 9 ça assez ça fait
que neuf films en manque trois
mouvements
donc là ça change rien ça mécaniquement
ça peut pas être connecté à ce côté là
mon dernier truc ça a été de baisser
celui ci si je le remonte ça fait quoi
quand ça referme petit je leur montrais
renferme c'était assez logique
est-ce qu'il est plus sorti que lui -
sortie
mais il est clairement plus sorti ici
que ici et on rentre voilà c'est un vrai
mouvement ça ouais
donc ça ça fera un dixième mouvement je
pense que je peux leur baisser 11
et là j'ai clairement libérer le tasso
donc en fait c'était pas dans ce sens là
c'est dans ce sens-là kisio voilà et 12
ouverture de la boîte douce thème de
yaws et guy jeu trop content c'est
tellement jolie s'est fait juste avec du
bois noble c'est très très joli et alors
comment ça fonctionne à l'intérieur je
vais essayer de voir assez drôle le
mouvement il reste secret parce qu'il ya
juste une toute petite rainures on voit
un petit assure l'intérieur qui bouge
il doit descendre ah ouais d'accord en
fait ça fait un chemin
c'est quand même un petit labyrinthe à
l'intérieur du truc assez ça ce bois là
il est creusée à l'intérieur avec comme
un petit système de labyrinthe pour un
petit bout de bois qui doit faire le
trajet en fait et c'est comme ça qu'ils
arrivent à faire certes mais du coup je
leur montre bon je me le refaire un coup
en accéléré pour voir si les uns oubliez
donc 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 et 12
et ça passe
merci d'avoir regardé cette vidéo vous
avez vu c'est flippant quand jésus très
pratique reculer un petit peu loïc s'il
te plait merci à aa
je suis faire c'est des conneries pompe
peur sur leur téléphone le lien dans la
description comme d'habitude le lien mon
instinct aussi dans la description je
vous le rappelle n'hésitez pas à venir
dessus je fais des vidéos que vous ne
voyez que sur un stade donc c'est assez
cool sur les casse-têtes entre autres
leaké la vidéo si ça vous a plu mais
témoin dans les commentaires les noms de
casse tête que vous aimeriez que je
résolve sur la chaîne c'est pas facile à
conjuguer un résolve résoudre tout ça et
puis abonnez-vous ce n'est pas déjà fait
à très bientôt ciao